then as we launch the counter-attack
against the Union Army must remember
that even though we may die a glorious
death on the battlefield we do so to
preserve a way of life the southern way
of life a way of life so pure and
beautiful that no man no government can
take this away from us
the right
the right to preserve our own son
[Music]
we look fellas we're trying to have a
nice little Civil War Reenactment here
we don't want any trouble so we sir we
try to have a real nice reenactment
we certainly don't want to cause any
trouble either do we say you are always
Tatars troubled only comes to those who
gone down looking south so don't stop
your speech as Jefferson did okay I know
what you're doing how many times do I
have to tell people just because we're
dressed like Confederate soldiers
doesn't mean we're pro-slavery we're
just here to preserve the pure and
beautiful slice of southern history yeah
pure and beautiful slice okay nobody's
gonna whip anybody just stop it yeah
just stop it all right fellas just just
ignore him all right now we're here to
preserve our way of life the South has a
right to own the south as a way of life
you need to not stop us
[Music]
the Union Yankee bastards cannot stop us
but don't stop stop it that's enough
want to be part of this reenactment fine
you're part of it go go go fetch us some
munitions and everything else it go just
a little like a bunch of lazy that good
enough for you that is all I needed to
hear gentlemen give us your cash and
anything that is an actual collector's
item you racist mother okay don't have
all day man okay thank you thank you
wallets wallets wallets wallets it's a
very nice piece these
you